[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
and welcome to I/O Live.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'm here with Iliyan,
who is a principal
engineer on Android
and he leads Project Treble.
Hi, Iliyan.
ILIYAN MALCHEV: Hello, Timothy.
How are you?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm super.
ILIYAN MALCHEV:
Excellent, thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So that
keynote was amazing
and there was a lot
of your work up there.
In fact, Project Treble.
I want to talk about that.
But before, could you
describe the problem?
What are you solving
with Project Treble?
ILIYAN MALCHEV:
What we're solving
is what we call Android's
version fragmentation problem.
Which is best explained--
if you're an app developer,
you have to deal with all
of these Android versions
that you have to
implement against.
And this is a massive
pain to deal with.
So this is the problem
that we started addressing
at with Project Treble.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And how you
solve that with Project Treble,
is you make it easier for
manufacturers to upgrade
to the latest version, right?
ILIYAN MALCHEV: Correct, yeah.
I mean, for developers
to have the latest,
device manufacturers have
to launch their devices
on the latest or upgrade
existing ones to the latest.
But historically it's
been very difficult, which
means expensive, to do that.
Which is why device
manufacturers simply
didn't do it.
This is why we have Android
version fragmentation today.
The way that we solve
it is effectively
by lowering their costs.
That's what Project Treble is.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, so Project Treble
was introduced last year.
What's new this year?
ILIYAN MALCHEV:
What's new this year
is that we effectively
completed the engineering
portion of our work
and we embarked
on an operational side of it.
Which the goal of it is to
accelerate the deliverables,
the intermediate deliverables
of Android, to the OEMs,
to the device manufacturers,
so that they can do their work
to launch these devices and
upgrade these devices much,
much earlier than previously.
So the end result is that we
expect companies like Samsung,
for example, to do their
work in the same year
when we launch Android.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
Now, what OEMs are launching?
ILIYAN MALCHEV: We
have seven companies,
in addition to Google's
very own Pixel of course,
who are launching
previews-- betas--
this year.
And these are Oppo, Vivo,
Nokia, Sony, Essential,
OnePlus, and Xiaomi.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
ILIYAN MALCHEV: That's
a lot of companies.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
you and I actually
have our pockets full
of some of these phones.
ILIYAN MALCHEV: Yes, we do.
We do.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Which
I think it would
be neat to show there's the
same version of Android running
on each of these
different phones.
ILIYAN MALCHEV: Yeah, that's
what's beautiful about this,
is that these are devices by
completely different companies,
which all run the same
version of Android.
That was never
happening until now.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
totally awesome.
ILIYAN MALCHEV: And there's
one more thing, of course.
In addition to these previews,
we have a total of 18 devices
by 11 manufacturers
who will either launch
or upgrade their existing
devices to the latest
of Android this year.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
ILIYAN MALCHEV: It is.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So for
developers, this, again,
really matters,
because it simplifies
their overall developer
experience, which
they can get started on by
downloading the preview.
ILIYAN MALCHEV:
That's exactly right.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Iliyan, thank you
so much for joining us
to explain all of that.
ILIYAN MALCHEV: Thank
you for having me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: To
learn more, head on over
to android.com/beta.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]